hello hello my name is Adam Smith
calling from nobelprize.org the website
of the Nobel Prize oh yeah
have you already heard today's news yeah
I heard the news I came out of the the
plane landing at 20:30 and then there
was a representative of the airport who
came with flowers and picked me up in a
car I didn't understand anything and
then finally I found out because I saw
that was 150 emails and 75 text messages
that I come in the last two hours and
then I thought I was one from your own
home zone
so then sort of things started to add up
I guess what it was but it took me a
little while but I'm terribly grateful
it's absolutely fantastic so and and
this year I I mean I I didn't even know
it was today I really didn't even think
about it but so even more pleasant one
has such a surprise indeed well what a
bewildering way to find out
yeah and have you managed to speak to my
Brit your wife yet I've tried to call
three times and I don't get through
I hope they will call back sooner or
later but the problem is that the list
of incoming phones is so so large so I
don't know if she but I I guess she will
find us lots to talk in a few minutes
I'm sure I was I was lucky enough to
speak to her a little while ago and she
so she said she cried when she heard the
news and also that the only sadness was
that you were on the plane and couldn't
share it but anyway I mean the important
thing is that this happened and it's
fantastic both for us and for the lads
for everyone who has supported us so
that's a lot of people I mean it is a
team work and it is lots of people who
are completely invisible like all the
people in the University and Geneva and
the people in the research council are
sort of giving us absolutely top
conditions for 20 years which has made
it possible to to do the research we are
done so a lot of people behind it it's
it's interesting that myprint made it
made the same point so you're obviously
in perfect synchrony there's the proof
and of course you see you've received
the prize with John Okeefe yes has been
something of a mentor at some points yes
so yes I mean in 1996 that probably
might be told you I worked there for
three months and she was the from one
month so he trained us to do the type of
single cell recordings that we have been
doing since and three months I spent in
his lab that's the most efficient
learning period I ever had I learned so
much and he took so much care of me and
spent so much personal time on me
so we she even I got a desk in his
office and I shared the same lab with
him so he's a fantastic mentor and
extremely advice that we can now share
the price together
have you managed to get away from the
airport yet or you still know I'm still
at the airport there's lots of people
standing here so they trying to get me
into the Max Planck Institute because
there's going to be a press conference
or two o'clock I probably better have to
leave but I saw that it was a number
from Sweden so therefore I I made an
exception and took the fall
great so so so so enjoy your day in
Munich a strange place and thank you so
much for speaking to us thank you